The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to do rolling caches then,
we're going to go a little
bit over amortized analysis
and if we have a
lot of time left,
we're going to talk about
good and bad hash functions.
So can someone remind me what's
the point of rolling hashes?
What's the problem?
What are we trying
to solve in lectures?
Be brave.
AUDIENCE: Gets faster,
I think, because like--
PROFESSOR: So what are
we trying to solve?
You don't need to
go ahead, tell me
what's the big problem
that we're trying to solve.
AUDIENCE: I don't remember/
PROFESSOR: OK, so
let's go over that.
So we have a big document,
AKA a long string,
and we're trying to find a
smaller string inside it.
And we're trying to
do that efficiently.
So say the big document is--
you might have seen this before.
And we're trying to
look for the here.
How do I do that
with rolling hashes?
So the slow, nice
solution is I get this the
and then I overlap with the
beginning of the document,
I do a string comparison.
If it matches, I say
that it's a match.
It's not, I overlap it here.
String match, I overlap it here.
String match, so
on and so forth.
The problem is this does a lot
of string matching operations,
and the string matching
operation is how expensive?
What's the running time?
AUDIENCE: Order n.
PROFESSOR: Order n, where n
is the size of the string.
So if we have a string,
say this is the key
that we're looking for and
n is the document size then
this is going to
be order n times k.
We want to get to
something better.
So how do I do this
with rolling hashes?
AUDIENCE: We take
the strings up,
and you come up with
a hash code for it.
PROFESSOR: OK so we're
going to hash this.
And let's say this
is the key hash.
OK, very good.
AUDIENCE: And then once
you know that, then you'll
need to compute the
next letter hash,
or just add it on
to that pairing.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
next letter for--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you compute the hash of the
entire string, n, capital n--
PROFESSOR: Let's not do that.
Let's compute the hash of
the first key characters
in the string.
AUDIENCE: Are we separating
them by space [? inside? ?]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this
is going to be a character.
AUDIENCE: The space will?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The space
will be a character?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let's take the
first three characters
and compute the hash of that.
And let's call this
the our sliding window.
So we're going to say
that window has the
and then we're going to compute
the hash of the characters
in the window, and
we're going to see
that this matches
the hash of the key.
And then we'll figure
out what to do.
That aside, we're going
to slide the window
to the right by one
character so take out
key and put in the space.
And now the window
has HE space, we're
going to compute the
hash of the window,
see that it's not the same
as this hash of the key.
What do we know in this case?
Different hashes means--
AUDIENCE: Not the same string.
PROFESSOR: For sure
not the same string.
So this is not the.
OK, now suppose I'm
sliding my window
so after this I will
slide my window again,
and I would have e space f.
Right, so on and so forth.
Suppose I'm happy sliding my
window and then I get here
and I have my window be IN
space, and the hash the window
happens to match
the hash of the key.
So we're in the same
situation as here.
Now what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good.
We have to check if the
string inside the window
is the same as the
string inside the key.
And if it is, we found a match.
If it isn't, we keep working.
All right?
And we have to do
the same thing here.
So this is our string
matching algorithm.
AUDIENCE: Can we somehow
make sure that we make a hash
function such that it
will never [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
Thank you, I like that.
Can we make a hash
function so that we
don't have any false
positives, right?
Let's see.
How do hash functions work?
What's the argument
to a hash function
and what's the return value?
AUDIENCE: The
argument is something
that you want to hash.
PROFESSOR: So in this case we're
working with three character
strings.
But let's say we're
looking for a one megabyte
string inside the
one gigabyte string.
Say we're a music
company and we're
looking for our mp3 file
inside the big files
off a pirate server
or something.
So this is 1 million
character strings,
because that's the window size.
And it's going to return what?
What do hash functions
return for them to be useful?
Integers.
Nice small integers, right?
Ideally, the integer would
fit in a word size, where
the word is the register
size on our computer.
What are popular word sizes?
Does anyone know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
32-bits, 64-bits integers.
OK, so what's the universe
size for this function?
How many one million
character strings are there?
AUDIENCE: How many
characters are there?
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
Let's say we're old school
and we're doing [? SG ?].
We don't care about
the rest of the world.
AUDIENCE: 256 characters?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: To the
one millionth power.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Let's say we're working
on an old school computer,
since we're old school and
we have a 32-bit word size.
How many possible values
for the hash function?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the 32.
PROFESSOR: The
[? other ?] is bigger.
You're messing with me, right?
OK so this is 2 to the 8th.
AUDIENCE: 2 to the
8 million, right?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So this is a lot
bigger than this.
So if we want to make a
hash function that gives us
no false positives,
then we'd have
to be able to-- if we have the
universe of possible inputs
and the universe of
possible outputs,
draw a line from every
input to a different output.
But if we have-- 2 to the 32 by
the way is about four billion.
If we have four billion
outputs and a lot of inputs
as we draw our lines,
we're eventually
going to run out of
outputs and we're
going to have to use the
same output again and again.
So for a hash function,
pretty much always
the universe size is bigger
than the output size.
So hash functions will
always have collisions.
So a collision for
a hash function
is two inputs, x1, x2, so
that's x1 is not x2, but h of x1
equals h of x2.
So this will always happen.
There's no way around it.
What we're hoping for
is that the collisions
aren't something dumb.
So we're hoping that
the hash function acts
in a reasonably randomly and
we talked about ideal hash
functions that would pretty
much look like they would get
a random output for every input.
And we're not going to
worry too much about that.
What matters is that as long as
the hash function is reasonably
good, we're not going to have
too many false positives.
So say the output set is
O, so O is 2 to the 32.
Then we're hoping to have
false positives about one
every O times.
So 1 out of 2 to the
32 false positives.
So what's the running time
for when you slide the window
and we're doing this logic here.
What's the running time if
the hashes aren't the same?
AUDIENCE: What's the running
time of the hash function--
PROFESSOR: Of the whole
matching algorithm.
AUDIENCE: No, no no, of
the hash function itself.
Can we make any
assumptions about that?
Very good.
What's the running time
of the hash function?
So we're going to
have to implement--
if we implement the
hash function naively,
then the running time for
hashing a key character string
is order key.
But we're going to come up
with magic way of doing it
in order one time.
So assume hashing is order 1.
What's the running time
for everything else?
So if the hashes don't match,
we know it's not a candidate.
So we're going to keep going.
So this is order 1.
What if the hashes do match?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
characters.
PROFESSOR: Order--
AUDIENCE: I mean, but it
depends on how many ones match,
but it will be--
PROFESSOR: So for
one match, what's
the running time for one match?
AUDIENCE: Order k--
PROFESSOR: Order k.
Excellent.
So the total running time is
the number of matches times
order k plus the number of
non matches times order 1.
So as long as the number
of false positives
here is really tiny,
the math is going
to come out to be roughly
order 1 per character.
AUDIENCE: So the whole
thing is order in.
PROFESSOR: Everything
should be order n, yeah,
that's what we're hoping for.
OK so let's talk about the
magic because you asked me
what's the running time
for the hash function
and this is the
interesting part.
How do I get to
compute these hashes
and order 1 instead of order k?
We have this data structure
called rolling hash.
So rolling hash--
does anyone remember
from lecture what it is?
AUDIENCE: Isn't that what
we're doing right now?
PROFESSOR: So this
is a sliding window.
And the data structure
will compute fast hashes
for the strings inside
the sliding window.
So how does it work?
I mean not how does it
work functionally, what
are the operations for a
rolling hash, let's try that.
AUDIENCE: Oh [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so
we have two updates.
One of them is pop.
For some reason, our
notes call it skip,
but I like pop
better, so I'm going
to write skip and think pop.
And the other one is?
AUDIENCE: Always [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A pen with
a new character, OK?
Cool.
So these are the updates.
Now what's the point
of those updates?
What's the query
for a rolling hash?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You just grab the
next character,
append that, and then
skip [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so this is
how I update the rolling hash
to contain to reflect the
contents of my sliding window.
And what I do after that?
What's the reason for that?
AUDIENCE: You skip
your [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So don't
think too hard, it's
a really easy question.
I moved a sliding window here.
What do I want to get?
AUDIENCE: You want to get
the hash of those characters.
PROFESSOR: The hash of
those characters, very good.
So this is the query.
So a rolling hash has a sequence
of characters in it, right?
Say t, h, e.
And it allows us to append the
character and pop a character.
Append a character,
pop a character.
And then it promises
that it's going
to compute the hash
of whatever's inside
the rolling hash really fast.
Append goes here,
skip goes here.
How fast do these
operations need
to be for my algorithm
to work correctly?
AUDIENCE: Order 1.
PROFESSOR: I promised
you that computing
hash there is order 1, right?
So I have to-- OK.
Let's see how we're going
to make this happen.
So these are letters.
These make sense
when we're trying
to understand string matching.
But now we're going to switch
the numbers, because after all,
strings are sequences
of characters,
and characters are numbers.
And because I know how
to do math on numbers,
I don't know how to
do math on characters.
So let's use this list.
Let's say that instead of
having numbers in base 256
which is [INAUDIBLE],
we're going
to have numbers in base 100,
because it's really easy to do
operations in base 100 on paper.
So 3, 14, 15, 92,
55, 35, 89, 79, 31.
So these are all
base 100 numbers.
And say my rolling
window is size 5.
One, two, three, four, five.
So I want to come up with a way
so that I have the hash of this
and then when I slide my window,
I will get the hash of this.
What hashing method do we
use for rolling hashes?
Does anyone remember?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Mod, you said--
I heard mod something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's what I said.
PROFESSOR: OK, so?
So?
So the hash is?
The hash of a key is?
AUDIENCE: It's k mod m or m k.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'm going to say
k mod something,
and I'm going to
say that something
has to be a prime number
and we'll see why in a bit.
Let's say our
prime number is 23.
So let's compute the value of
the hash for the sliding window
of the first sliding
window and then we'll
compute the hash for the
second sliding window.
Oh, there is some at
the computer, sweet.
314159265 modulo 23 is how much?
OK, while you're doing
that, can someone
tell me what
computation will he need
to do for the second
sliding window?
AUDIENCE: 1519265359.
PROFESSOR: 159265359.
AUDIENCE: That's a third sign.
AUDIENCE: There's
a 1-4 before that.
AUDIENCE: The first one is 11.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And what's the second one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] adding--
PROFESSOR: 1415926335 modulo 23.
AUDIENCE: 5.
PROFESSOR: I heard a 5 and a 7.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hold on, hold on.
PROFESSOR: I'll take
the average of those two
and we can move on, right?
AUDIENCE: Three
five, and arguably 6.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so let's implement
an operation called slide.
And slide will take the new
number that I'm sliding in.
And the old number
that I'm sliding out,
making my life really easy.
So in this case, the
numbers would be--
AUDIENCE: The new one is 35.
PROFESSOR: And the old one?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
And I want to have an internal
state called hash that has 11
and I want to get 6 after
I'm done running slide.
This is still too hard for me,
so before we figure out hash,
let's say that we have an
internal state called n.
And n is this big number here.
So I want to get from this
big number to this big number.
What am I going to do?
AUDIENCE: Mod 3,000 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so you want
to take the big number 159265
and mod it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if I mod
it to by a big number,
that's going to be too slow.
So I can't mod it.
AUDIENCE: Can't
you just divide it?
PROFESSOR: Division
is also slow,
I don't like the division.
I like subtraction,
someone said subtraction.
So what I want to do is I want
to get from here to a number
that-- to this number, right?
So I want to get
rid of the 3 and I
want to add 35 at the end.
To get rid of the 3,
what do I subtract?
AUDIENCE: 3 with a bunch of 0s.
PROFESSOR: 3 with a bunch of 0s.
Excellent.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
How many of them are there?
AUDIENCE: 8.
PROFESSOR: OK, how many
digits conveys 100?
AUDIENCE: Oh, 2 right?
AUDIENCE: 4.
AUDIENCE: Oh, oh.
PROFESSOR: 4.
So base 100, so two numbers--
AUDIENCE: One base 100
number is two digits.
Yep.
PROFESSOR: So 8.
yeah, OK, 4.
Cool.
So let's try to write this
in a more abstract way.
So n is the old n
minus old, right,
so that 3 is old times what
do I have to multiply it by
to get all those zeros?
k minus 1?
[INAUDIBLE] to
that base whatever.
PROFESSOR: OK, so-- base
to the size to something.
K minus 1.
So K is 5 in this case, right?
My window is 5.
And I see a 4 there, so I'm
going to add the minus 1
just because that's
what I need to do.
OK, so then I get 14159265.
What do I do to tack
on a 35 at the end?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 35.
PROFESSOR: OK, times
the base, so that's
going to give me the zeroes.
And then this is a minus here.
And then I'm going to add 35.
Right?
1415926535.
Look, it's right.
So what do I write here?
AUDIENCE: The base first.
PROFESSOR: Good point.
OK.
Let me play with this a little
bit before we go further.
I'm going to distribute
the base here.
So this is n times
base minus old times
base to the k plus mu.
And let's rename base to size
to be the size of the window,
I don't like k.
And I'm renaming it
because later on we're
going to break our slide
into appends and skip
and the size won't
be constant anymore.
OK so does this make sense?
It's all math.
So this math here becomes
abstract math here.
But nothing else changes.
OK, so now I want
to get hash-- I
want to get hash out
of n, how do I do that?
AUDIENCE: Mod 23.
PROFESSOR: Mod 23, very good.
So in a general way,
I would say mod p.
OK so hash is n times
base minus old times
base to the size plus new mod p.
Now let's distribute this.
I know I can distribute
modulo across addition
and subtraction, so I have n
mod p times base minus old times
base to the size mod p plus new.
And everything still
has to be a mod p.
So can someone tell me
where did I add the mod p?
Why did I put it here and here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the original?
PROFESSOR: OK, nmodp
is hash, let's do that.
So what's true about both
n and base to the size?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
PROFESSOR: Constant?
AUDIENCE: Like can
you please repeat it?
AUDIENCE: You could [INAUDIBLE]
base to the size but you
can't [INAUDIBLE] hash,
I mean [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Hm.
OK, so keep this in mind
that we can compute this,
because we're going to
want to do that later.
But what I had in mind is
the opposite of constant,
because n is huge.
Right?
And base to the size
is also huge, right?
N is this number.
Base to the size is
this number here.
1 followed by this many zeros,
so these numbers are big.
All the other numbers are small.
Base is small, old is small,
new is small, p is small.
PROFESSOR: So I want to
get rid of the big numbers,
because math with
big numbers is slow.
So unless I get rid
of the big numbers,
I'm not going to get
to order 1 operation.
So we already got rid of
this one because it's hash
and how do I get
rid of this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: There's
some 6042 algorithm
that does that quickly.
AUDIENCE: Well, we definitely
just went over this in class
today.
AUDIENCE: Which is why you
needed the prime number, right?
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
There is an algorithm
that does it quickly.
That algorithm is
called repeated squaring
and the quickest-- wait, I'm not
done, I promise I'm not done.
So the quickest
that this guy can
run if you do everything right
is order of [? log ?] size.
If the window size
is 1 megabyte,
10 megabytes, if the
window size keeps growing,
if the window size is
part of the input size,
is this constant?
Nope.
So I can't do that.
Someone else gave me
the right answer before.
What did you say before?
AUDIENCE: Pre-compute it?
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's a constant, so why
don't we pre-compute it?
Take it out of here,
compute it once,
and after that, we can
use it all the time.
And unless someone has
a better name for it,
I'm going to call this magic.
The name has to be
short, by the way,
because I'll be writing
this a few times.
OK, so now we have hash
equals hash times base
minus old times magic
plus new modulo p.
Doesn't look too bad, right?
Pretty constant time.
Now let's write the pseudo
code for the rolling hash,
and let's break this
out into an append
and a skip at the same time.
AUDIENCE: What if hash is
bigger than your word size?
PROFESSOR: So hash is always
going to be something modulo p.
AUDIENCE: Oh that's true, OK.
PROFESSOR: So as
long as p is decent,
it's not going to get too big.
AUDIENCE: All right.
What if old and
new [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: So old and new--
AUDIENCE: P is a big number .
314159269 is possibly bigger
than your word size, right?
PROFESSOR: Definitely.
So that's why we're
getting rid of it.
AUDIENCE: That is
true. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this is
k digits in base b.
Too much.
Not going to deal with it.
Hash is one digit in base p,
because we're doing it mod p.
Old and new are
one digit base b.
So hopefully small numbers.
OK, I haven't seen a
constructor in CLRS,
so I'm going to say that
when you write pseudocode,
the method name
for a constructor
is in it because we've
seen this before.
And let's say our constructor
for a rolling cache
starts with the base
that we're going to use.
And it builds an
empty rolling hash,
so first there's nothing in it.
And then you append and you
skip and you can get the hash.
AUDIENCE: What about p?
Shouldn't you also do p?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Do that.
So let's say base and p are set,
so somethings sets base and p.
And we need to compute
the initial values
for hash and magic.
What's hash?
Zero.
There's nothing in there, right?
The number is 0.
What's magic?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Well, I mean, you can
calculate it, right?
PROFESSOR: So magic is
based to the size mod p.
What size?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 0.
Just one mod p.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So when I start, I have
an empty sliding window.
Nothing in there, size
is 0, base to the size
is 1, whatever the size is.
Very good.
Let's write append.
Hash is?
So here, we're doing both
an append and the skip.
We have to figure out
which operation belongs
to the append, which
operations belong to the skip.
So someone help me out.
AUDIENCE: We know subtraction
would [INAUDIBLE]--
AUDIENCE: Multiply
mod base [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So this is the append, right?
And this is the skip.
So hash equals hash.
Times base plus new mod p.
Very good.
This is important.
If you don't put
this in, Python knows
how to deal with big numbers.
So it will take your
code and it'll run it,
and you'll get the
correct output.
But hash will keep growing
and growing and growing
because you're computing
n instead of hash.
And you'll wonder why
the code is so slow.
So don't forget this.
What else do I need to update?
OK, I don't have a
constant for that,
but I have a constant
I for something else.
Magic.
So magic is base
to the size mod p.
So what happened
to the window size?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Times base [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
The window size grows
by 1, therefore,
I have to multiply this by base.
Magic times base mod p.
AUDIENCE: Does p always have
to be less then the base,
or can it be anything?
PROFESSOR: It can be
bigger than the base.
So if I want to not have
a lot of false positives,
then suppose my base
is 256, because that's
an extra character.
I was arguing earlier that
the number of false positives
that I have is 1/P basically.
So I want p to be as close
to the word size as possible.
So p will be around
2 to the 4 billion.
So definitely bigger.
It can work either way.
It's better if it's
bigger for the algorithm
that we're using there.
All right, good
question, thank you.
Skip.
Let's implement skip.
Hash is?
AUDIENCE: Hash minus old
[INAUDIBLE] then comes magic
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, can I
write this in Python?
What happens if I write this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
magic is, [INAUDIBLE] We
won't be able to find it.
PROFESSOR: OK so--
sorry, not in Python.
So assume all these are instance
variables done the right way,
but what happens if old times
magic is bigger than hash?
I get a negative number.
And in math, people
assume that if you
do something like minus 3 modulo
23, you're going to get 20.
So modulo is always positive
in modular arithmetic,
but in a programming language,
if you do minus 3 modulo 20,
I'm pretty sure you're
going to get minus 3.
And things will go back.
So we want to get
to a positive number
here so that the
arithmetic modulo
p will work just like in math.
So we want to add something to
make this whole thing positive.
AUDIENCE: That's something
times [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so if
we're working modulo p
then we can add anything to
our number, any multiple of p,
and the result modulo
p doesn't change.
For example, here to get from
minus 3 to 20, I added 23.
Right?
OK, so I want to
add a correction
factor of p times something.
So what should that be?
I want to make sure that
this whole thing is positive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So let's see.
How big are these
guys, by the way?
Magic is something mod p, right?
So it's definitely
smaller or equal to p.
How about old?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So smaller or equal than?
AUDIENCE: Base.
PROFESSOR: Base.
Very good.
So this whole
thing is definitely
going to be smaller
than [INAUDIBLE].
So this is definitely going to
be smaller than base time p,
right?
So let's put that in here.
You can get fancy and say
hey, this is smaller than p,
and this is old, so you can put
old here instead, same thing.
OK so we have hash.
Now what do we do to magic?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] divide
it by the base and mod p.
It seems base [? and p ?]
don't share factors.
You're allowed to do that?
PROFESSOR: OK, so skip part two.
Magic equals-- So what if
my magic is something like 5
and my base is 100?
How is this going to work?
This is where we use fancy math.
And I call it fancy
math because I
didn't learn it in high school.
So I'm assuming at least some of
you do not know how this works.
So if we're working
modulo p, you
can think 23 if you prefer
concrete numbers instead.
For any number between
1 and p minus 1,
there's something called
the multiplicative inverse,
a to the minus 1,
that also happens
to be an integer
between 1 and p minus 1.
And if you multiply, say, a
times b, that's another number.
And then you multiply
this by a minus 1,
you're going to
get to b modulo p.
So a minus 1 cancels
a in a multiplication.
Now let's see if you guys
are paying attention.
What's a times a to
the minus 1 modulo p?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Sweet.
So suppose I want to find the
multiplicative inverse of 6.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Is that the mod 23?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Can someone think of
what it should be?
AUDIENCE: 4.
PROFESSOR: 4, wow, fast.
So 6 times 4 equals 24,
which is 1 modulo 23.
Now let's see if this magic
really works, this math magic.
So 6 times 7 equals?
AUDIENCE: 42.
PROFESSOR: Which is what mod 23?
Computer guys.
AUDIENCE: Negative 4, so 5.
Ah, just kidding.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK now
let's multiply 19 by 4.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: 76.
PROFESSOR: All
right, 76 modulo 23?
AUDIENCE: 7 maybe.
PROFESSOR: Are you kidding?
Did you compute it,
or did you use--
AUDIENCE: 69 [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Started with 7, ended with 7.
So this works.
So as long we're working
modulo a prime number,
we can always compute
multiplicative inverses.
And Python has a
function for that,
so I'll let you Google
its standard library
to find out what it is.
But it can be done,
that's what matters
as far as we're concerned.
So we're going to say that magic
is magic times base minus 1 mod
p, which is the multiplicative
inverse everything mod p.
Now suppose this base
minus 1 modulo p,
this multiplicative inverse
algorithm is really slow.
What do we do to stay order 1?
Pre compute it.
Base is not going to change.
Very good.
So the inverse of base, I
base, is base minus 1 mod p.
So here I replace
this with I base.
OK so skip part one is
there, skip part two is here.
Does this make sense so far?
I see some confusion.
AUDIENCE: A lot.
PROFESSOR: A lot
to take in at once?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So remember this concept.
So this is where
we started from.
Then we computed
n, then after n, we
worked modulo p
to gets to hashes.
So by working module p,
we're able to get rid
of all the big
numbers and we only
have small numbers
in our rolling hash.
And there's that
curveball there, there
is that inverse,
multiplicative inverse,
but Python computes
it for you, so
as long as it's in
the initializer,
here you don't need
to worry about it,
because it's not part of
the rolling hash operations.
By the way, what's the cost of
the rolling hash operations?
What's the cost of new?
Sorry, what's the
cost of append?
Not thinking here.
Constant.
All these are small
numbers, so the arithmetic
is constant, right?
What's the cost of skip?
Skip part 1 here,
skip part two there.
What's the cost of skip?
Constant. .
All the numbers are small.
We went through a lot
of effort to get that,
so skip is order 1.
We're missing hash.
How would we implement
the hash operation?
A hash query.
It's easy.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
lookup [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So a rolling hash
has append, skip, and hash.
I want to implement
that hash function.
Hash.
We're computing
hash all the time.
Return.
Sorry, I didn't understand
what you meant by lookup.
AUDIENCE: It's
one of our states.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
So the hash function
returns hash, right?
What's the cost of that?
Constant.
So append is constant time, yes?
Skip is constant time.
Hash is constant time.
We're done.
This works.
Any questions on rolling
hashes before you
have to implement
one of your own?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
wouldn't it
be easier to use
a shift function?
Then you don't have to
think about plus and minus.
PROFESSOR: A shift function.
AUDIENCE: Well I mean like,
you can shift bit-wise, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So you
can just use shift
instead of thinking
about where to add this,
where to subtract this.
PROFESSOR: Well so
I do bit operations
if I'm willing to work
with these big numbers.
AUDIENCE: But then
you have to compute
the mod of some
big number, right?
Like just like that.
For this one, you don't
have to, because you
have the original
hash [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh, you
mean the big number
being the actual word
you're looking at?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So doing shift
is equivalent to maintaining
a list and pushing and
popping things into the list.
And then you have
to do a hash, it's
equivalent to looking
over the entire list
and computing the hash function.
Because you'd have a big
number and you have to take
it modulo 23.
And that's order of the
size of the big number.
But we're not
allowed to do that.
Hash has to be constant time,
otherwise this thing is slow.
AUDIENCE: Why do we
compute magic numbers then?
PROFESSOR: Why do
we compute magic?
We compute magic because
somewhere here, we
had this base to the size
mod p and this could get big.
So I can't afford to keep
it around and do math
with it all the time.
So I can't compute
base to the size
every time I want to do append.
AUDIENCE: Would it be worth
it if you're computing 100
different values for
matching and [INAUDIBLE],
so all you'd have to do
is, when reassigning magic,
just look up--
PROFESSOR: So if you
do that, then you
have to compute values
for all the sizes, right?
For all the window sizes.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So if we assume that window
sizes will be less than 100,
it doesn't take very long.
PROFESSOR: Well what if the
window size is 1 million?
What if I'm looking
for a 1 million
character in a 1
gigabyte string?
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't after
all, wouldn't the size just
be around the string, like plus
or minus the size of the base?
So--
AUDIENCE: Only if [INAUDIBLE]
So why would the
size change again?
Why wouldn't it
just be-- I mean,
if you're looking
at one character.
PROFESSOR: So if I have a
sliding window like this,
then it doesn't change.
But if I want to
implement a rolling hash,
that's a bit more general and
that supports append and skip.
Whenever I append,
the size increases.
Whenever I skip,
the size decreases.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you're not doing
those at every time step.
You're doing them as needed.
PROFESSOR: So I'm
trying to implement
that, that can do
them in any sequence.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I thought we were just
doing sliding window.
PROFESSOR: So if we're just
doing sliding window, you can--
AUDIENCE: This is really
more caterpillar hash instead
of rolling hash, like
it's more general.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's a bit more general.
So let's look at rolling
hash for the window.
And what you're saying
is, hey, the window size
is constant, so--
AUDIENCE: Why do we
repeat magic [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if the
window size is constant,
then we wouldn't re compute it.
It wouldn't change.
But with this thing, it's not.
OK.
AUDIENCE: But I guess it
doesn't really matter,
but even if you call
these in the same order,
then isn't that wasting
a lot of computing cycles
because just shrinking and then
growing every single operation?
PROFESSOR: Oh, well it turns out
that a lot of computing cycles
is still order one, right?
Everything is order one.
So as algorithms
people, we don't care.
If you're doing it in a
system and you actually
care about that, then OK.
But you're still going
to have to compute
the initial value at some point.
AUDIENCE: But if you know
window's staying the same,
you don't need to that
computation every time?
PROFESSOR: If you-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: If you
know you're actually
just doing a window
rolling hash--
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So then you would
initialize magic here
to be whatever you
want it to be, right?
But then when you add the first
few characters to the window,
you have to figure
out how to add them.
So the code gets more messy.
It turns out that
this is actually
simpler than doing it that way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
magic I guess
I'm just confused because it
seems like we're still working
with the large numbers
every time [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Let's see.
Mod p, mod p.
AUDIENCE: That's not-- so even
though you're still multiplying
magic times base,
it doesn't matter.
PROFESSOR: After I'm going
that, I'm reducing it modulo p.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
because we're only
working with the smaller values.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So everything here stays
between 0 and base or 0 and p.
Actually hash is between 0 and
p and magic is between 0 and p.
OK.
AUDIENCE: How big
does p usually get?
PROFESSOR: How big
does p usually get.
So And let me get back to this.
So I was arguing that the
number of false positives
here is one over O, right?
is the number of values that
the hash function can output.
How many hash functions can we
output using a rolling hash?
AUDIENCE: P.
PROFESSOR: P. OK.
So the number of
false positives is
1/P. So what do we want for p?
AUDIENCE: We want p to be the
word size, because but if p's
the word size, then--
PROFESSOR: So p can't
be the word size,
because it has to
be prime, right?
But we want it to be big,
because as p becomes bigger,
1/P becomes smaller.
So there are two constraints.
We want p to be big
so that we don't
have a lot of false positives.
And we want p to be
small so that operations
don't take a lot of time.
So in engineering, this
is how things work.
We call it a tradeoff
because there
are forces pushing in
opposite directions,
and it turns out that a
reasonable answer to the trade
off is you make p fit in a word
so that all those operations
are still implementable
by one CPU instruction.
You can't have it
be the word size.
So if we're working
on a 32-bit computer,
I can't have this
be 2 to the 32.
But I can have a prime number
that's just a little bit
smaller than 2 to the 32.
AUDIENCE: Wait, why can't
it be the word size?
Or why can't it be 2 to the 32?
PROFESSOR: So if p would
be this instead of a prime,
then I can't do this.
AUDIENCE: Oh, right right
right, yeah I knew that.
PROFESSOR: There are a
lot of moving parts here
and they're all interconnected.
AUDIENCE: You could do that
for any prime number, right?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So this works for
prime numbers, but it
doesn't work for
non prime numbers.
AUDIENCE: You could find
the multiplicative inverse
for any prime number in base 32.
Is that true?
I mean any odd number is
what I'm trying to say.
No, that's not true.
PROFESSOR: I refuse to
answer hard math questions.
AUDIENCE: They need to
be relatively prime.
They need to share no factors.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
it might be true.
AUDIENCE: So an odd will
not share a factor with 2
to the 32?
PROFESSOR: You're forcing
me to remember hard math.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I totally
just thought about this
as [INAUDIBLE] number.
PROFESSOR: So, no, it
turns out that there's
no-- if you're working modulo
and non prime base, then
there's no
multiplicity inverses.
So some numbers have no
multiplicative inverses,
and other numbers have more
than one multiplicative inverse.
And then the whole
thing doesn't work.
So let me see if I
can make this work
without having an
example by hand.
Let's say we're
working mod 8, right?
Mod 8.
So 2 to the minus 1 mod 8 is
not going to exist, right?
AUDIENCE: Right, but 3 will.
PROFESSOR: 3.
Let's see what do we use?
3 times 3 is 9, right?
So this is 1.
How about 3 times 5?
15 mod 8 is 7.
So 3 and 5, and then--
AUDIENCE: 11.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So 3 times 7 would be 21, 5.
OK so 3 and-- 3 is the
multiplicative inverse
of itself, and 5
and 7 are-- yeah.
I have to build a more
complicated example,
but this breaks
down in some cases.
I'll have to get back to you.
I will look at my notes
for modular arithmetic
and I'll get back to
you guys over email
for why and how that breaks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can
you tell me again
why we did the part 2 in skip?
Like why did we do that?
I'm not really sure [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we
started with magic 1
and then we-- in order
for this to work,
we agree that magic will be
base to the size modulo p
all the time.
So this has to be [INAUDIBLE]
invariant for my rolling hash.
When I do an append,
the size increases by 1.
And then I multiply
by base to modulo p.
When I do a skip, the
size decreases by 1.
So I have to change magic,
because magic is always
base times size, so
I have to update it.
So this is why this happened.
Because initially,
I wanted to update
by dividing it by base, right?
Magic divided by base.
But if magic is 5
and base is 100,
we're not going
to get an integer.
And we want to stay
within integers,
so that's when I pulled
out fancy math and-- OK.
OK.
So how are we doing
with rolling hashes?
Good?
AUDIENCE: All this math
will be in the notes, right?
PROFESSOR: Everything.
Oh, yeah, everything else
will be in the notes.
Before we close out, I want
to show you one cute thing.
Who remembers
amortized analysis?
I know there's one person
that said they understood.
All
PROFESSOR: The growing,
shrinking thing
is what we did in lecture.
I want to show something else.
I want to show
you a binary tree.
A binary search tree, because
you've seen this on the PSAT
and you already hate it.
AUDIENCE: Why'd they
call it amortization?
Because I looked it up
online, it means to kill,
and so I'm like, why not say
like, attrition or something
else that's a little bit less--
PROFESSOR: Amortization is
also used in accounting to mean
you're--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Let's use the
growing hash example,
because that's good for
why this is the case.
So when you're growing your
table, you're inserting.
If you still have
space, that's order one.
If not, you have to grow
your table to insert.
And that is more expensive.
That's order n where n is how
many elements you had before.
So if you graph this
costs, if you start off
with a table of size one, you
can insert the first element
for a cost of one.
For the second element, you
have to resize the table,
so it's a cost of two.
Now when you're trying to
insert the third element,
you have to resize the
table again to a size of 4.
But when you insert the
fourth element, it's free.
Well, cost of one.
When you insert
the fifth element,
you have to resize a table
to the size of eight, right?
So The table size is one, two,
four, four, and now it's eight.
But because they
resized this to eight,
the next three assertions
are going to be order one.
And then the one after that is
going to make the table be 16.
So I can do seven
insertions for free
and then I'm going
to have to pay
a lot more for the next one.
Someone said dampening.
I like dampening because
the idea behind amortization
is that you can take--
you have these big costs
and they don't occur very often.
So you can think of it
as taking these big costs
and chopping them up.
For example, I'm going
to chop this up into four
and I'm going to take this
piece and put it here.
This piece and put it here.
And then I'm going to
chop this guy into two,
and then take this
piece and put it here.
And the beginning's
a little bit weird,
let's not worry about
that but this guy,
if I chop this guy up into
eight, it's going to happen,
is it?
Well we can put-- so this guy
grows exponentially, right?
Every time it's multiplied by 2.
But the gap size here
also is multiplied by 2.
So when I chop this up and
I re distribute the pieces,
it turns out that the
pieces are the same size.
So if I apply a dampening
function that does this,
then the costs are going
to look-- they're not
going to be on
one, they there are
going to be three or something.
And they look like this.
Now, my CPU time is going
to look like this, right?
That's not going to
change, because that's
what's really happening.
But what I can argue
for is that if I
look for a bunch of operations,
say if I look at the first 16
insertions, the cost of those
is the sum of these guys.
So it's not been
squared, which is
what you would get if you
look at the worst cases here,
but it's order n.
So this is what's
being dampened,
the amount of time
an operation takes.
Does this make some sense?
All right, I want to show you a
cute example for amortization.
And I'll try to make it quick.
So how do you list the keys in
a binary search tree in order?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: In order
traversal, right?
OK, there's another
way of doing it
that makes perfect
intuitive sense.
Get the minimum key, right?
And then output the
minimum key, then
while you can get the
next largest, which
is the successor--
so while this is not,
now output that key, right?
If you do the thing
within order traversal,
you get order end running time.
What's the running
time for this?
AUDIENCE: For n.
You're going through
all the keys, too.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but next largest--
what's the running
time for next largest?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
PROFESSOR: So this
guy's log in, right?
So I have n keys, so this
whole thing is O of n logn.
So it's definitely not
bigger than n logn.
But now, let's look at what
happens using the tree.
When I call min, I
go down on each edge.
And then I call successor
and it outputs this guy.
Then I call successor
and it goes here.
Than I call successor and
it goes up here and here
and outputs this guy.
Successor goes here.
Successor goes all the way down
here, successor goes up here,
successor goes here,
and then successor
goes all the way up to
the roots and gives up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So how many times
do I traverse each edge?
Exactly twice, right?
How many edges in the tree?
If I have n nodes, how many
lines do I use to connect them?
[INAUDIBLE]
So 1 node, zero lines.
2 nodes, one line.
Three nodes, two lines.
So n nodes, n minus one.
N asymptotically, good.
Good answer.
Order, n, edges.
Right, each edge gets
traversed exactly twice.
So amortized cost for n next
largest operations is order n.
So you can do this instead.
This code makes a lot more
sense than in order traversal.
OK, and the last part
is remember that list
query that was on the PSAT?
Turns out you can do a
find for the lowest element
and then call successor
until you see the highest
element for the same argument.
Well, I couldn't tell
you this for the PSAT
because we hadn't learned
amortized analysis,
so you wouldn't be able to
prove that your code is fast.
But now if you
get the intuition,
you can write it that way.
And your code will
still be fast.
Same running time.
So the intuition for that
is a bit more complicated.
The proof is more complicated.
But the intuition is that
say this is l and this is h.
Then I'm going to go
in this tree here.
So the same edge magic
is going to happen,
except there will be logn
edges that are unmatched here
and logn edges that
aren't unmatched here.
Because once I find the
node that's next to h,
I'll stop, right?
So some edges will
not be matched.
So then I'll say that the total
running time is logn plus a.
AUDIENCE: i being the number of
elements you pull out, right?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So this is amortized analysis.
The list is hard.
The traversal is easy.
Remember the traversal.
That's easy to reason
about, so that's good.
OK.
Any questions on
amortized analysis?
So the idea is that you
look at all the operations,
you don't look at one
operation at a time.
And you're trying to see
if I look at everything,
is it the case that I have
some really fast operations
and the slow
operations don't happen
too much, because
if that's the case,
then I can make an argument
for the average cost, which
is better than the argument
that says this is the worst
case of an operation,
I'm doing an operation,
the total cost is n
times the worst cost.
Make some sense?
OK.
Cool.
All right.
Have fun at the next p set.